постривай
хто ви активіст чого
це Московського патріархату
Я як активіст і намалюю вашу локацію
цілковито
в Україні
[музика]
Може на вихід не треба не треба нормально
Я теж громадянин України і мені говорив
Я не хочу мені не дозволяє
Та тому що там їх немає Якби я там
знав що вони є я б пішов до Служби
Безпеки
тільки одному богові, бо він почекай
тому що він є єдиний
власник єдиний власник
який створив небо та Землю на якій
знаходиться Україна Грузія Молдавії вся
планета і тільки йому потрібно підносити
Славу розумієш, а Україні ти можеш
підносити честь
але не Славу Слава може належати
Одному Богу, який створив це все і
тебе зі мною в тому числі розумієш Ви
молоді Слава Україні я тобі поясню
якщо ти хрещений
то треба вчити свою віру свою вчив
зрозуміло що ти сьогодні славитимеш
Україну завтра ти будеш кричати